au coeur de la gestion de cette crise le
gouvernement legault mais aussi le
docteur horacio arruda
c'est mon invité bon ce que je joins ce
soir bonsoir dr arruda
merci d'être avec nous ce soir bonsoir
le show alors on vous a vu un extrait
d'un petit florilège comme on fait
souvent 24 60 et des extraits de vos
déclarations ces jours derniers on sent
bien votre état d'esprit
il reste que ce bilan du québec peut
faire sourciller fait réellement
sourciller parce qu'on a un très mauvais
bilan
quel est votre diagnostic là-dessus
basse écoutez c'est clair qu'en termes
de transmission communautaire le bilan
est excellent par contre je joue
absolument pas ni le drame dans les
sièges et celle des c'est véritablement
un drame
je voudrais je sais ce qu'est vraiment
fait de québec se retrouve dans une
situation je vous dirais qu est
absolument pas enviable et ça nous
questionnent beaucoup et très
honnêtement pour moi ce seuil
chacun des dessins ces cdo est un drame
la façon dont ça s'est passé ou si
c'était un drame mais mais par contre
pour ce qui est des 38 cents
communautaire pour ce qui est d'avoir à
choisir en des personnes ou pas dans des
soins et ans est violée dessus le
confinement les élections du québec ont
fonctionné en même temps il ya le
plusieurs qui remettent en question
l'idée de ces paris s'est passé en 6 h
et 6 h et celle dite du reste de la
population faisait quand même la
population qui a introduit que ce soit
des travailleurs de la santé qui ont eux
mêmes été victimes ou même des visiteurs
venus d'ailleurs donc notre bilan est un
des pires au monde la sait salon peut
pas se réjouir de sa non non jour il
faut dire que je sais pas de 2,2
d'éliminer le phénomène oddsson sa
dignité sa vie n'était d'autres s'est
tenu les mains faut être capable de
démontrer l'autre élément par contre si
vous me permettez puis s'en remettent en
cause le drame que ça te présenter parce
que chacune des mort est une mort
importante au québec on est vraiment un
système de très sensible par rapport à
la mort tu étais dans plusieurs pays
actuellement c'est quand ils vont
regarder leur surmortalité comme telles
a causé ce thème qui sont pas les mêmes
vont découvrir ailleurs aussi eu
beaucoup de drames en lien avec les
personnes âgées etc
mais c'est clair je trouve cela et
comparaison pour les frères en pro ils
savent avec les besoins intérieurs
on avait un très grand problème au
québec un très grand problème qu'on a
pas vu venir
moi je vois honnêtement je ne
m'attendais à ce que deco dans les ces
sociétés mais la quantité de ressources
étaient manquantes des conditions dans
lesquelles des gens travaillent et le
manque de personnel ça a été vraiment un
élément explosif
oui parce que dès le début de la
pandémie nous à cette émission on en a
parlé dès le 20 janvier on en a parlé
presque tous les jours depuis le début
vous êtes venus d'ailleurs cette
émission quelques reprises on a pensé
faire un petit exercice son exercice
partiel vous allez le reconnaître avec
moi mais on veut rien entendre quelques
extraits des entretiens qu'ont eus
ensemble au début puis tous les
scientifiques s'entendent pour dire
qu'on découvre et le virus au fil des
jours puis vous avez dit souvent mais ce
que je dis aujourd'hui sont peut-être
pas plus vrai demain mais ça va réfléter
l'état d'esprit dans lequel on n'étaye
au plus de cent jours parce qu'on parle
déjà de la fin janvier on écoute ce
monsieur au japon revient ce qu'on va
nous virus l'a complètement aux strass
semble devenir syndrome moins sévère que
des gens qui vont avoir plus qu'on me
room la peur si très mauvaise
conseillère
puis la peur la façade et acer a pas de
crise de bon sens même advenant le code
de confirmation d'un qu'au québec le
risque de transmission de la maladie de
la communauté demeure également faible
est ce que des mesures particulières ici
qui devant une prise pour protéger les
plus vulnérables
une bonne proportion des gens ont faim
maladie ministre se soit pas le mal est
sévère mais nos personnes âgées des gens
qu'on des cancers etc
je pense que sans le dessin tout prix
éviter d'aller les rencontrer les
mesures qu'on veut faire c'est pour
aplatir une courbe
alors de terre dont on voit bien que on
veut bien quoi vous laisse répondre est
un peu des trois petits points
le côté on voit bien que c'est un virus
qui était nouveau et émergents chacune
des faces fallait pas non plus on est
arrivé à une technique ou au phrase
initiale
mais c'est sur quelque part toujours
dire moi probablement la chose qui
meublent plus traumatisé c'est bien
entendu ce qui s'est passé dans les
faits c'est celle des monts en le voodoo
virus
c'est le fait que sa virée cela pouvait
se transmettre avant même déjà des
symptômes et puis puis de l'autre côté
je pourrais crier au loup à l'époque au
mois de janvier on aurait probablement
dit attention la clé tu exagère mais ça
démontre toujours
enfin quand il faut toujours se préparer
dans une perspective non c'est parce que
bon on s'en va parce qu on a dit dès le
début on a tiré les leçons du strass on
a tiré les leçons du maire sont de tirer
les leçons du h1n1 or c'est à refaire
vous venez d'évoquer les cas
asymptomatiques ont découvert encore de
route que les asymptomatiques était
vecteur de ce virus est contagieux
infectieux mais au début on ferme les
frontières bon james avait des symptômes
restez chez vous empêche juste les alors
deuxième vague vous l'avez dit d'entrée
de jeu il y en aura une
alors si on doit refaire les choses là
où est ce qu'on va tester les
asymptomatiques qui reviennent de voyage
on va fermer les frontières plutôt qu
est ce que vous vous referiez
différemment en vue d'une deuxième vague
ou d'un nouveau virus qui pourrait
frapper parce qu'on sait qu'un hors
d'eau écoutez c'est clair c'est clair si
vous permettez que la question de fermer
les frontières
puis il faut comprendre que c'est
toujours fait c'est-à-dire les
cosmétiques puis fermé des frontières
qui sont sous l'autorité du gouvernement
fédéral c'est pas un enjeu qui souffre
c'est le cas ça c'est clair que je vous
êtes notre fameuse semaine de revanche
et puis ce qui se passe les frontières
par prenons l'exemple britannique très
bien évolué et puis un jeu très content
pour eux comme tel très rapidement la
chine refermer ses vols tout ce qui
s'appelle l'ouest
je voudrais jusqu'à nadeau puis l'ouest
américain il ya effectivement eu d'écho
mais rapidement comme les frontières se
sont permis c'est beaucoup de
travailleurs des gens qui viennent de la
chine
la bombardements étaient deux sur un an
au québec ait eu la fameuse semaine de
relâche et eu la france
d'état dit des gens vont beaucoup dans
ces pays là il ya eu les orques qui avec
des communautés
ça a été un bombardement qui kills elle
sonnerait coupé sort intérieurement on
aurait probablement mieux agi par contre
on avait quand même des problèmes il y
aura fini par entraîner virus telus
quand même le problème des sièges et
celle d il faut pas se le cacher ouais
mais en même temps si on l'avait fait
c'est facile à dire après les voir une
commission technique qui va peut-être il
ya enquête du coroner
vous allez tout mettre sur la table les
informations vous avez vous avez
collaboré parce qu'il faut aller au fond
des choses on peut pas se satisfaire de
chiffres et statistiques pas toutes
façons les sciatiques joue contre nous
aussi oui non créés mois je retire le
très honnêtement à chaque fois chaque
jour les descendants de prison on on le
fait du mieux possible avec toutes les
incertitudes scientifiques que ça
présente c'est clair qu'on va collaborer
parce que moi honnêtement et eicher vous
dire tout de suite là on va jouer vous
quand on relâche et par exemple on ne
fait les écoles en périphérie toujours
monde du mouvement au canada personne ne
voulait quand on fait ce qu'on le fasse
on en est venu et nous que le risque
était potentiellement gérable
heureusement les enfants sont pas très
malade
c'est clair qu'on a pris énormément de
choses à vous dire une chose
on va prendre encore au courant et
processus puis nous là on n'est même pas
terminée cette sexy qu'on est déjà en
train de penser à la prochaine justement
le docteur forte chez votre homologue
américain dit je veux pas parler de
deuxième vague mettant ne pas finir la
première vague
votre impression c'est que notre
première vague n'est pas terminée encore
le premier revers retourner dans bonne
direction ok on voudrait que sur les
ressorts de la saisonnalité second
permet tait de telle sorte qu'au québec
et seulement c'est le moment le mieux à
un moment provins pour des cons finis
parce que vers est sûr que le pottok ça
par contre pour moi la lady confinement
massif qu'on le fait pourrait entraîner
une recirculation qui ramènerait je
voudrais une recrudescence de cette fac
ci mais le crash pas de deux et vague
je parle de véritablement deux camps la
saisonnalité du et rejoint recommencer
ce qu'on pense c'est à l'automne puis
ali du pilat mais ce qui est très bien
c'est que
les états du sud américains on pense à
la floride est exact l'arizona il ya des
augmentations incroyable de colle et
pire depuis le début et dont on est
toujours dans la première vague les cas
augmentent il fait chaud alors et plus
questionné la saisonnalité
elle peut varier aussi le pays alors que
facteurs peuvent être faits puis
effectivement les endroits où ça lui
pose circuler c'est en train de circuler
et d'ailleurs dans le monde alors que
celle avait arrêté ça recommence
notamment pékin
il faut vraiment être aux aguets autres
aux aguets mais maintenant vous allez
beaucoup de pression puis a pas de
décision qui vient de québec ou de votre
part le masque vous avez des
professionnels qui vous demandent
recommandé le masque aujourd'hui on
apprend que la californie demande
maintenant le masque dans les endroits
publics
la main des devil de la floride du texas
de l'arizona vont imposer le masque
alors qu'est-ce qui pourquoi vous lui
faites pas si on parle pas de toi
policier sylla mais ne serait-ce que
d'éviter de commettre à nouveau des
erreurs
à partir du moment où on sait maintenant
que c'est un bon outil de contrôle
c'est aussi sa jauge en tir debout oui
je vous remercie pour la question vous
savez la chose la plus importante à mon
sens et qu'il fallait apprendre aux
québécois c'est que la meilleure mesure
de protection sa voix demeurée la
distanciation de battre saint c'est
véritablement à mon avis la meilleure
mesure ceux ci allie gêne respiratoire
aiguë la vache de m et axa si maintenant
on masque on le recommande très
fortement je porte partout matin suite à
l'extérieur que je vous racontais
quelqu'un du même espace mais c'est ça
laissez-moi terminée ouais pour ce qui
est de rendre obligatoire je pense qu'on
veut on est en effet réalisme tous nos
experts extrêmement nuno pour
recommander je vais vous dire c'est ce
que que sauf sous la lumière des groupes
de médecins qui ont fait déjà mais quand
au regard des gens qui font de la liste
et public les effets pervers de rendre
obligatoires les effets sur les
populations qui ont des problèmes qui
vont être plus vulnérables qui ont poli
masse qu'est ce qu'on va faire on veut
seulement donné ça pour vous dire juge
ou d'une chose si vous permettez
on va voir ce que l'avenir nous réserve
l'enfant on compte sur la conviction à
l'ap
obligation s'il faut contrainte on ira
là contre vous savez déjà que les états
où il ya eu les masques et au parc
culture de ce respect les pays d'asie là
ils ont ils ont porté puis les cas on
était mieux contrôler les bilans sont
meilleures oui dans des gens qui ont
déjà porté le masque depuis longtemps
ils le sont de façon adéquate
je m'entraîne vous dire là ça fait pas
patiné personnel d'ailleurs je le dis je
le recommande fortement
puis je reconsidère aux québécois plutôt
confus obligé de rendre obligatoire
commencer dont elle fait par contre si
vos petits dans un contexte de deuxième
vague où on verra les décisions qui sont
prises je peux m'avancer aujourd'hui
pour donner une date
mais c'est aussi là est pris en très
sérieuse considération
et même si on m'a accusé de dire que je
crois être inquiété pour les masses
ce que je vous disais et encore je dis
encore c'est un important la preuve que
c'est super efficace demeure encore à
démontrer du débat scientifique là
dessus ce qui classe il faut l'utiliser
mais surtout pour parvenir à un
confinement comme on le vit quand tu es
en main soyons distincts de 2 m saint
jean la façon de travailler
on va en parler de triche ali parce
qu'on doit aller une pauvre conne en
effet argent notre nouvelle normalité
on peut parvenir à assen pandémie au 29
on pourrait travailler différemment on
peut socialiser différemment mais le
devin pour demeurer à mon avis c'est
comme si on fonctionne dans une société
mais on ne prenait pour jude confinées à
la maison du docteur arruda
on a parlé du masque après la pause en
date entre décision vous avez beaucoup
de pression là-dessus
parlons du confinement il ya beaucoup de
déconfinement qui frustre beaucoup de
monde dans le milieu culturel
dans la main dans le monde des
spaghettis pourquoi les piscines
publiques sont ouvertes les bébés ne
sont pas je vais je vais citer monsieur
legault cette semaine au jour dans le
journal dans son antre journal de
montréal lisez moi j'ai juste senti très
seul
je crois que vous avez accueilli selon
monsieur harouna parce que vous étiez
avec lui tous les jours mais sur le
confinement
c'est délicat il dit ils ont été près
mais d'autres a good day today près de
tarhouna à réaliser quelques jours de
plus mais a choisi de suivre et il a
choisi de suivre son instinct je sais
monsieur legault est ce que c'est vrai
écoutez je dois vous dire moi je prévôté
savidan les aborder une question si vous
demandez un gouvernement de tous ces
essais désactivez votre autres niveaux
de sécurité et la gelée vendus mais je
ne m'attendais pas à une prise en compte
de cette nature au dos parce que j'avais
le goût est reconnu comme étant un homme
qui veut revoir l'économie du québec
c'est très bien donc j'arrive avec mon
histoire le virus grippaux qu'il aurait
été une catastrophe si on fait pas les
actions comme tel et vouloir rejouer
très honnêtement que je livre en lui
mais je m'attendais pas à ce qu'ils
répondent bouche aussi dû le faire
s'arrêter pour comme pour moi ce ménage
n'a pas ce que j'ai pu accomplir pendant
dix ans et les arrivées jours et dont on
ne peut agir très rapidement mais je dis
que vous voudriez faire plus tard le
confinement
vous vous dites que le buteur c'est ces
deux journées mais les journées
automnales à québec ont offert cette
semaine
vous comprenez que je devais le faire
cette semaine c est lui et rapide
j'aurais pensé pendant 48 heures n'ont
pas pris la décision dans ce sens sur la
censure mais je le préside a fait
quelque chose et est alors qu'ils ont
confiné ailleurs il ya des secteurs
concernés
alors messieurs de poésie et sérieux une
question de chanter alors on y va parce
que chaque jour où on a des mesures de
contrôle puis c'est ce que vous nous
disiez en début serait ça sauve des vies
mais les mesures de contrôle sont
arrivés tranquillement pauvres et
plusieurs ont soulevé la question je
peux pas ne pas vous la posez docteur
arruda vous la fameuse semaine de
relâche vous étiez au maroc vous êtes
resté en vacances via une vidéo qui
circule et où vous moquer un peu du
virus
est-ce que vous avez des regrets est ce
que si vous aviez été aux commandes
ici vous auriez senti l'urgence que nous
on sentait ici l'heure quand on était
sur le terrain écouter même chose les
dit plusieurs fois pour vous je vous
réponds encore une fois je reçois cette
réunion ge se fait facilement
je vous cherchiez avant de partir
j'avais collé téléthon je veux dire les
gens ce qui s'y passe est en contact
régulier avec mes équipes que j'ai vu
tous mes courriels d assister à
l'annoncé du premier cas au québec et si
chanter ma présence physique sur place
allaient changer les choses
j'suis allé par un engagement de
présentation très nettement plus profond
de mon coeur ma présence physique au
québec pour y échanger l évolution ni à
aller à la prise des décisions
j'étais en contact régulier et j'avais
dit je crois que ce soit pour changer le
jour je vais revenir
il rappelait les gens pourront penser ce
qu'ils veulent de ça je peux vous dire
et en ayant été à santé publique depuis
des années une montée des vacances
régulièrement et serge et élabore je
demeure convaincu et avait des gens qui
aiment les orientations les gens tentent
de provisionnement peut-être qu'au temps
où est ma présence ici au québec aurait
pas été fait en éjectant humaine dans la
nuit ou un décalage horaire labour
capable d'être parce qu'une des choses
qui a manqué en début cette matière a
donné l'impression laissée par la presse
qu'on le su que ce qui se disait à
québec avec le trio dont faisait partie
c'est ce qui m'inquiète matériel ou on
le rationnel
et qu'au fond au final ça a pu avoir des
conséquences extrêmement dramatique on
n'avait pas toute la transparence à
laquelle on aurait dû s'attendre à ce
que la fraîcheur il ya du monde qui ont
pris de matériel on est malgré les
directives on étend les jours question
complexe
je peux vous dire du matériel était
excessivement des fonds pour deux jours
le bleu aux éléments les choses on était
là et un réseau complexe comme le no il
peut arriver dans les pays où les frais
de distribution et un endroit
l'anomalie matériel il méritait le
cessez le feu de son et les commandes
auraient été par rapport au matériel un
peu dans n'importe quel crime un moment
donné on est vraiment des commandes
s'étaient promis pour le québec ont été
arrachés ou même voler la chine et la
france à dimanche un moment donné le
hall était dans une situation
ça devenait s'il même que je peux vous
dire qu'ils en approvisionnant chez nous
on lui dit de toutes sortes
d'informations avec des fausses pistes
de griffiths et tout a été fait dans mes
merveilleux un problème ce genre on
pourra faire la lumière sur tout ça et
surtout elle afin de ça vous dirait que
ces problèmes-là est faible et cela soit
corrigé par pour la 2e phase et 2 les
mots teintés qui sont arrivés des sièges
au moins les choses on se questionne la
façon aussi dont on fait de ne prendre
soin des personnes âgées dans notre
société mais parce qu'au fond là si on
voit venir la deuxième phase vous dit
qu'on ne va pas confiné j'ai des
questions rapides pour vous savez je
compte faire mort pour tous parce que
est ce que vous êtes de ceux qui croient
que le remède le confinement est pire
que le virus lui-même et donc on irait à
la pièce c'est ça on est bien
moi je pense qu'on filme encore pire que
virus parce que sans confinement
on aurait été dans des choix si vous
permettez ou dans le premier en vain
qu'on a connu en plus du drame déchets
cd on aurait eu des jeunes ou des gens
pour lequel on a eu le soutien de soin
correctement dépassé pendant l'été où
j'ai choisi gré et monsieur x selon le
projet d'accord c'est clair à moins de
vie qu'on a c'est le plus d enfants sont
moins mars que vous prévoyez les enfants
c'est pas eux les transmetteurs les
personnes j'ai agi comme les flux
l'oiseau dont ils vont pouvoir
probablement et rend pas à l'école ne
repose infirmer ce secteur nous partons
on ne sait jamais comment les rues soit
frappé cet objectif
c'est dire si les gens avaient tous les
gens vont restera-t-il sur les gens même
si un des deux mains et comme si dans
les péquistes ont pas fini puisque force
est avec vous mais on sait jamais ce qui
va arriver
avez vous d'autres annonces à faire et
déjà qu'ils attendent encore le des
annonces en avez vous d'autres oui oui
ou telle heure vous comprendriez et je
peux comprendre les gens ils disent
pourquoi moi puis lui puisqu'on part
celui confiné c'est pourquoi dit c'est
juste
tout le monde sait les stations
ressasser les gens préfèrent il faudrait
sept classes et c'est travailler avec
des experts avaient déjà arrêté
travailleurs de ces secteurs là y'a des
geeks alors ça en vaut plus l'air aussi
au fait que l'on voit si ce qui reste
fermée lors briser aussi tout est ouvert
saute et se sent lié au cours des
prochains jours
à ce moment là les choses on est fiers
parce que les gens d'affaires mais deux
compagnies aériennes une lettre ouverte
aujourd'hui dans le globe and mail qui
disait au premier ministre l'écouté de
toutes les provinces et du canada fait
quelque chose leur père minutes
permettez nous de revenir à une certaine
normal normalité d'une certaine manière
des questions sur le traçage monsieur
trudeau a annoncé finalement sa décision
au service avait coulé le puits une
dizaine de jours le chapelet faille pour
le traçage dépistage on était faible sur
le dépistage et le traçage conviendrait
à ça a pris du temps
edge ou pour ce qui est du stage on a
atteint le 14 mai on voulait avoir un
moment donné mais safina je dis
seulement que vous compreniez - co le
niveau tess est plus important c'est
qu'on ait cette capacité au moment où le
désert à urmatt et des jours puis avant
il ya eu une augmentation
on va tester et on va aller au ski les
défis qu'elles sont très sages ont eu
des travaux qui ont été faits
c'est un humain et 1,5 complet dix
autres interventions mais qui vient pour
implanter une maison de santé publique
prise de risque et sont depuis longtemps
et comme le canada on va probablement
avoir à prendre une décision
visuellement c'est ça plus le djia qui
vont l'utiliser mais savoir est de 10 kg
à voir ici
la meilleure c'est là disons déjà parce
que si seulement 20% des gens
l'utilisent c'est là pour le potentiel
et même application que je peux parler
pour des surprenants vont certes à
consulter sur le réseau n'est pas la
solution
j'ai l'impression qu'on ressent ligne et
probablement sur les mains font train
parce que le principal on s'aime plus
envoyer dès que la question la
confidentialité des données des
questions et on va les présente en
rafales de terreur ou d'homme ça touche
les personnes de 70 ans et plus que se
sentent oubliés que ce soit pauline
jacobs il faudrait peut-être mais c'est
à nouveau les conseils pour les 70 ans
oui ce trou d'air connaît-il du
déconfinement des 70e images y en a qui
pensent encore enfermés chez eux le dr
arruda
rené lachance est ce que les aînés à
domicile seront dès qu'on finit même
sans la présence d'un vaccin
puis je peux rajouter delajoux dit les
roues qui est je suis passé à la 110ème
plus mais tu sais ce que je peux aller
en voiture avec une amie cet été c'est
tellement compliqué vos conseils
l'interprétation même la police sans
faire juste part des voix l'expression
d'un contraventions pour des jeunes 80
je comprends très honnêtement le jour
dit le citoyen de ses citoyens tiens moi
mon sens faut juste qu'ils comprennent
lui puis surtout chez les mêmes et du
poney comme un puzzle chronicles mineurs
sont tous d'avis mais très honnêtement
on est neuf mois les personnes de 70 ans
sont déjà des conflits des questions
d'interprétation fini je suis toujours
étonné d'entendre des histoires
d'horreur ou d 1,70 en portant ces gens
là puissent marcher le constate jean
l'automne
j'espère voir avec cela nos discussions
nous avons soixante dix est en bonne
santé
pour respecter les consignes de revenus
une vie quasi normale et les petits
enfants avec leurs grands parents
je vous dis et puis tu sais moi je juge
pas nécessaire de passer au préfet je
pensais jamais dans lego calais dans le
cou d'un gros khaled al quds l'écouté je
pense on verra mais je pense honnêtement
que malheureusement pour toutes sortes
de raisons aux personnes des gens on
préfère toujours le scellement des
consignes
j'ai compris c'est mon départ c'est
clair pour vous dire c'est vrai ce sens
est en bonne santé
reprenez une vie normale les marchés
nord ont fini et même eu des situations
où dans les rp orléans s'empêcher de fos
est bien aussi c'est d'autres actions
sont pas pour d'autres personnes
un des règles dernière question vous
avez été portée aux nues vous êtes
devenu une star il ya eu toutes sortes
défi
t shirt ce que vous voulez les semaines
ont été plus difficiles vous avez été
écorchée avez vous l'impression que
votre crédibilité en a pris un coup
votre moi ce qui est important pour moi
c'est le les gens aient confiance est ce
que ma crédibilité
on a pris un coup les gens vont juger le
net
moi j'ai toujours agi seul avec toutes
les équipes de santé publique
la pression de l'ue et c'est clair que
confiné c'est facile c'est clair qu'on
fini l'autre m'a vous permettez est
toujours été moi même ou ses succès là
je vais pas chercher
j'ai toujours su parce que ce qui monte
très haut que redescendre prévost me
gonfle à la tête du tout avec ça mais je
pensais toute ma vie à vouloir aider et
protéger les gens en fonction des
annexions débuté tambour et dans
l'effondrement celle ci y aura des
gagnants et des perdants des gens qui
vous dit que vous me direz peut pas
lever 19 existants machination qu'on a
trop fait et qu'on a détruit certaines
industries
moi je n'ai rien eu on ne fait on
pouvait est ce qu'on a fait de mieux de
demeure excessivement préoccupé par le
drame dont des véhicules quant aux dans
les maisons pour leur proposer docteur
arruda merci beaucoup d'avoir passé ce
temps là avec nous ce soir et on se
repère merci à tous un bon et puis c'est
le mas - vient d'émettre les maths et
demi ça ça va faire partie de notre
entrevue à ce soir merci des travaux
d'abord celle de m